before we get started here today I need
to mention something that I announced on
Joe Rogan's show yesterday I'll have
more to say about the interview with Joe
Rogan and the great conversation we had
later on in the show for now we'll let
you know that the first 15 minutes of my
film what is a woman are now available
to watch for free and for non-members at
what is a woman.com if you haven't seen
the film yet haven't yet been convinced
that it's uh worth getting the
membership for head over to
whatahswoman.com for an extended preview
and as I said we'll talk more about the
interview with Joe Rogan a little bit
later on uh now as voters head to the
polls today Democrats you know those
Fierce Defenders of the democratic
process have already sent the word out
don't trust the results
at least don't trust them at first to be
more specific the Democratic party
message about voting results is that you
shouldn't trust them until they the
Democrats start winning
ABC News makes the case in typical
fashion warning of a red Mirage not a
red wave but a red Mirage
they say as early Election Day Results
come in on Tuesday will likely appear
appear that Republican candidates vying
for any number of the federal or
Statewide races appear to be leading
their Democratic opponents even by large
margins their leads will dwindle or
crumble completely after perceived dumps
of votes are recorded by state election
officials who count mail-in and absentee
ballots in the days or even weeks
following election day this phenomenon
was popularized as the red Mirage or the
blue shift after the 2020 presidential
election when former president Donald
Trump took a deceptive lead in several
competitive States on Election Day due
to delays and Counting of Democrats
mail-in ballots their preferred method
of voting due to the kova 19 pandemic
only to eventually dissipate when the
entire reserve of votes was totaled
um
now
that's what they say but if kovid was
allegedly to blame for the alleged red
Mirage then why are they warning that it
will happen again I mean the pandemic is
over remember Joe Biden said so himself
ABC continues this is likely to occur
again on Tuesday according to election
experts because of the same cocktail of
factors that led to a red Mirage in
2020. Democrats have continued to use
mail-in voting more than their
Republican counterparts while some of
the same decisive States will take a
longer time to tally their mail-in
absentee and provisional ballots due to
state laws that prohibit their account
until late stages in the electoral
process and it's likely to occur in some
of the same states where the phenomenon
presented itself last cycle in States
like Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin
Battleground states that also happen to
feature some of the most hotly contested
races of the election season
so the real cocktail of factors is that
these states choose to count their
ballots this way even though they don't
have to in fact the article acknowledges
that after the chaos of the 21 election
there were bipartisan calls for States
like Pennsylvania Wisconsin to change
their laws to make it easier to count
the ballots on Election Day
they chose not to make the change
so it doesn't have to be this way
it never was this way until just two
years ago
but now that it is this way Democrats
say it must be this way and it should be
this way I mean this is the leftist
specialty right radically changing
something and then insisting that the
thing now changed could never be
anything other than what it is now even
though it was something else entirely
five seconds ago
that was basically Karen Jean pair's
message yesterday from the White House
here she is
it took two weeks to call every state in
modern elections more and more ballots
are being
early voting and also by mail and many
states don't start counting those
ballots until after the ballots uh after
pardon me after the polls close on
November 8th so you heard the president
say this the other night he has been
very clear on this as well we may not
know all but winners of Elections for a
few days it takes time to count all
legitimate ballots in a legal and
orderly manner that's how that's how
this is supposed to work and it's
important for us to all be patient when
wild votes are are being counted
that's how this is supposed to work
there is of course it's supposed to take
weeks is what you just said
now there's of course no reason at all
why it should take days much less weeks
to count ballots
she says that these are modern elections
well in any other context the mark of
modernity is that things are done
quicker and more efficiently
why should it take longer to count
ballots in 2022 than it took in like
1802.
they say the reason is that so many
people have voted early and by mail well
that explanation doesn't really make
sense because if you have the ballots
early shouldn't it be if anything easier
to get them counted on Election Day
if it isn't if early voting really makes
it somehow impossible to declare a
winner on the same day or even the same
league
then that's all the more reason to
abolish early voting
putting aside active duty military
perhaps a few other isolated exceptions
the drawbacks of early voting and mass
mail and voting are substantially
greater than the advantages obviously
that's a rather easy judgment call to
make because there really aren't any
advantages significant enough to be
factored in or weighed
the current system you know with mail
and voting and early voting it affords
people the opportunity to vote in their
pajamas with as little effort as
possible and without leaving their homes
okay
that doesn't solve any problem or meet
any pressing need
there's nothing wrong with requiring
minimal effort from the electorate in
fact it's a positive good to acquire
minimal effort
and besides even with same day in-person
voting you can still vote in your
pajamas it's not like people care about
dressing presentably in public these
days anyway so the advantage is that it
makes it makes even easier something
which was already extremely easy
arguably too easy
what are the drawbacks
well with early voting for one thing
you're voting before the campaign is
over
the candidates haven't finished making
their cases you may not know everything
you need to know about them what if a
candidate just to pull an example at
random
say has a stroke and becomes brain
damaged after you've already voted for
him now in fetterman's case the brain
damage happened before the primaries had
even finished but it still demonstrates
the sorts of surprises and changes that
can present themselves during a campaign
all the more reason to vote at the end
of The Campaign not in the middle of it
I mean there are a lot of people who
after that debate with fetterman and Oz
a couple weeks ago decided to uh that
they didn't want to vote for fetterman
anymore
well some of those people had already
voted for him
for another thing early voting does in
fact provide more opportunities for
cheating whatever you think about the
prevalence of cheating there is no
debate that the longer you take
to count the ballots the more
complicated and confusing it is the more
chances for funny business to occur and
and that's obviously going to be the
case
and finally the current system to use a
phrase that we so often hear from
Democrats these days
um destabilizes our democracy
and there seems to be no disagreement on
this point right the media the White
House the Democrat Party they all
acknowledge that when States take days
or weeks to announce a winner in highly
contentious and pivotal races it creates
lots of public anxiety and concern about
the integrity and reliability of the
results
they openly admit this they're
predicting it
they tell us ahead of time that
Pennsylvania will take forever to count
its ballots because it shows not to fix
its balance accounting system and that
this will create from the perspective of
a wide swath of the population
the appearance of impropriety
well here's the point
even if you don't think that cheating is
happening or that it will happen even
though it certainly does and will in
every election
the fact that doing it
this way causes many people to have less
less faith in the results that's reason
enough to not do it this way
the Citizens need to trust the results
if they don't the whole system breaks
down
that is the house of cards that the
entire system is based on the trust of
the electric if you don't have that you
don't have anything
do the Democrats not see or not
understand these immense drawbacks to
mass early voting and mail and vote no
of course they see it and they
understand it but to them
these are not drawbacks they are the
point they are features not bugs
we can only conclude that they want
people to vote early and vote by mail
because it means they're locking in
their choice before the campaign is over
and because it gives the opportunity for
let's say post-election adjustments
quote unquote and because it
destabilizes our democracy
the the one thing they claim to fear the
most is exactly what they in fact want
and are attempting to engineer
because the left seeks always to
destabilize destroy demoralize
preservation even of democracy is never
their goal
and that's all the more reason why they
need to pay the political price
they need to be thrown out of office
and we have to do it with the system
that is currently in place however
horrifically flawed it may be
take over the system and fix it that has
to be the goal
but it starts with your vote
so that'll do it for this portion of the
show I hope you get out and uh vote but
before you do we'll get over to our
member block of the program and I hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]